[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Thank you, Paul,
for introducing me.
And it's now my pleasure to
introduce Dr. Alexander Wait
Zaranek, or Sasha, whom I
know since 2006, as I met him
as a co-founder of
the-- in the very
early days of the-- Harvard's
Personal Genome Project.
We were working to get it to
the green tea line at Huntington
and then said, oh,
I've also in-- then
from the beginning, wow.
And now it's 2016.
And we were working together.
And the Personal
Genome Project has
grown beyond any expectations
that we had back in 2006.
We had one participant
at that moment.
So we couldn't know
how it would develop.
So currently Sasha
is the co-founder
and the chief
scientist at Curoverse,
which is a venture-backed
company focused
on building free and open
source platform for storing,
analyzing, and sharing
biomedical data.
Sasha works on
open technologies.
That's also part of the
tradition of the Personal
Genome Project, of course, open
data collection and open data
sharing.
And those technologies are
part of the revolution that's
reduced human DNA
sequencing cost
by a million-fold since the
completion of the Human Genome
Project.
So in the early 2000s,
it was a million times
more expensive to sequence the
human genome than it is now.
So this is unprecedented
development.
The current-- Sasha's
current research focus
is on the development of
clinical quality applications
for processing massive
data-- data sets
spanning millions of
individuals across collaborating
organizations.
This is-- usually these are
something like consortiums,
huge collaborations,
and eventually
encompassing exabytes of data.
And I must confess that I
didn't know what exabytes were.
I did just a test
back in the lab
and asked a very
established colleague.
And he hadn't heard of it,
which made me very happy.
But I'm sure Sasha's going to
explain to you what exabytes
are.
And Sasha's
contributions have led
to highly cited publications
in Science, Nature,
and the Lancet and
other leading journals.
And he's now going
to tell you something
about tiling the genome,
naming the parts of genome that
make you you.
Sasha?
-Thank you so much, Jeantine.
Hi, everybody.
So I'm going to start by showing
you a piece of my genome.
And here it is.
This is one little piece of it.
If you look at the green
dot, there is a C right here
where my genome may be
different than most of yours,
although there's probably a
few people in this room that
have that same feature
in their genome.
And this is very
strongly associated
with high cholesterol.
You know, my mother had
a tendency toward it.
My grandmother did.
It's a very
well-established finding.
We know that high cholesterol
can be quite clinically
significant.
But interestingly enough,
after much research and effort,
it was found that
people who do have
this feature in their
genome don't necessarily
have a significant association
with heart disease.
So, you know, genomes
are complicated.
And this is really only about
a millionth of my genome.
We have an awful lot
of genome to show you
if I just sat there showing
you slides of my genome.
And we happen to know
something about this feature.
But there's lots of
features in genomes
we don't know so much about.
Now, as Jeantine
mentioned, we're
both co-founders of the
Harvard Personal Genome Project
that George Church
started in 2005.
So an interesting
thing about my genome
is that you can go to
this URL, and you-- it's
completely public.
And you can download my genome.
In fact, there are several
copies of my genome
that were independently
sequenced.
And so if you need some data
to play with, there it is.
And I was actually just
chatting with some members
of the audience.
And we have at least
one high school student,
not to signal you out.
But obviously, if
you're in high school
and you want to study genomes,
well, who is going to let
you study really
confidential data?
So people like me who
wanted high school students
to be able to study genomes
made their data public.
And so I think it's
very gratifying for me
to see such a wide audience
that isn't necessarily just
biomedical researchers, because
I think in the end all of us
have genomes.
And all of us should
be able to study them.
And it would be nice if there
was public data that you could
play with that would give you
kind of a sense of what can you
learn from a genome in
a kind of hands-on way
that you couldn't
learn necessarily.
And you may be very
private about your genome.
You might think we public
genome-sharing people
are crazy.
But you would still
benefit from having genomes
to play with yourselves.
Obviously, the world's
biomedical data
will mostly be private.
But it's very helpful to have
a collection of public genomes
so that we can kind of get
a feel for what's possible.
So how are we
going to make sense
of genomes, my genome,
any particular genome?
Well, the only
way is to sequence
lots and lots of
people and to carefully
phenotype those people, really
look at their medical records,
look at their history,
their medical history,
and amass all of
that data together
to look at it in large cohorts.
So we need lots of genomes to
understand even one genome.
And luckily, that's not
too much of a problem,
because over the
next five years we
will sequence at least
five million whole genomes
and probably more
than that portions
or smaller portions
of the genome.
And this is a lot of data.
It's about 500,000 terabytes.
That's half an exabyte.
And that's something-- you know,
these days a little hard drive
can easily store a terabyte.
So, you know, 500,000 hard
drives is still a lot of data
if you are-- want to share
it with your colleague.
So how are we going to do this?
How are we going to
amass these data sets?
make them useful?
So the way that we're
going to do it is we're
going to build on the commons.
And this is something
that, in IT,
the Googles and
Apples of the world
have all been doing for years.
So the most kind of well-known
foundation in this space
is called the Free
Software Foundation.
It's here in Boston.
And their mascot is this
little guy over here.
The Penguin over here is Linux.
So if you have an Android phone,
then it's powered by this guy.
And if you have an
Apple iOS phone,
it's powered by the BSD demon.
They're both free software.
At this point, the vast
majority of computing devices
in the world are all
running free software.
And this-- as a businessperson
and a scientist, this
is actually a big
deal, because it
used to be that we just couldn't
imagine how you could possibly
have software businesses that
gave all their software away.
But it turns out that
over the last few decades
this has become very
well established.
There's billions of
dollars of venture capital
investment in IT companies
whose products are all actually
open source.
OK, so on the software side,
part of building on the commons
is this free software idea.
On the data side, let's build
on the Personal Genome Project.
So at Harvard, we--
these are the PGP 10,
or the first 10 participants
in the Personal Genome Project.
One of our goals
has been to scale up
the project when we
could sequence people
for about $1,000 per person.
And recently a
company called Veritas
that is co-founded
by George Church
and some of my colleagues has
announced a commercial offering
where you can get your
genome for $1,000.
They will give it back
to you if you want.
And if you want,
you can donate it
to the Personal Genome Project.
You have to go through the
Personal Genome Project consent
process.
And you really have to think
about what you're doing
and pass an entrance exam
and some other things.
But at this point, it
is actually possible
that we've hit this
goal that we've
had for a decade of
the $1,000 genome.
The other thing that's
important for these kinds
of scientific studies that the
Personal Genome Project offers
is that we offer cells.
So if you're a
biomedical researcher
and you need an
actual tissue sample,
then participants that want
to donate those tissue samples
can do that through the PGP.
And there's various
bio banks that
will store those
tissue samples and make
them available to researchers.
And the most successful
example of this at this point
is the National Institute for
Standards and Technologies
has chosen two families
from the Personal Genome
Project, a mother, a
father, child, two trios,
to be kind of the
reference material genomes.
So those are now very
widely available.
And if you are a
clinical lab and you
want to sequence a genome,
you can order these materials
from NIST and use that to
validate your sequencing so you
actually know that your
sequencing process is good
and not just nonsense.
So PGP has already
really made quite a lot
of impact with an incredibly
ardent but small volunteer
staff.
So the questions I've
been thinking about
with my colleagues at PGP, with
my colleagues at Curoverse,
with students, have been
around this question of, well,
how do we organize the sort
of computational resources
so that when a scientist
asks a question, when
a member of the general
public asks a question,
or when a physician
asks a question
about a genome or about
genomes in general,
that we can actually
answer those questions?
Because obviously, as I sort
of alluded that-- there's
going to be 5 million genomes.
But those 5 million
genomes are going
to be spread all over the world.
It's a huge amount of data.
It's all locked in little silos.
How are we going to ask
questions of these data?
And if I ask a question
of your genome,
how do I know that
when I'm asking you
about a bit of your
genome that we're
talking about the same
part of your genome?
This is where the title
of my talk comes from,
is that we need all
this infrastructure
to make it possible
for us to share.
But we also need to just be
able to make sure that we're
talking the same language.
So I'll give you an
idea of how we do that.
So what do we have now?
Well, these hard drives sit on
benches pretty much everywhere
that sequences genomes.
Genomes are often
delivered as hard drives.
This is quite an old picture.
And so the hard drives have
gotten a little bit smaller.
And they store a
little more data.
But it's still the same horrible
method it's always been.
If I asked-- if I gave you 5
million of these and told you,
well, I need to ask some simple
question, you know, I mean,
it takes an hour just to
load one of these hard drives
onto your computer.
It's really totally impractical.
And also, they fail, and they
overheat, and you lose data.
And it's really terrible.
So we need some
kind of platform.
We need something.
We need some big,
big standard platform
that people use to make
this data available
that can be everywhere around
the world, sort of a planet
scaled.
And the features I think about
that a platform like this
has to have are
these four things.
And these are really
unique, because some of you
may know that big
data is something
in the news all the time now.
There's lots of
companies that are
creating products for big data.
But biomedical big
data is actually--
despite all of its similarities
with the rest of the big data
world, does have
interesting, unique features.
And so these are four of them.
So one of them is
that in biomed we
need to share more than
in other organizations.
Our regulation and our
security requirements
are among the most
complex in the world,
especially in tension
with our need to share.
Because obviously, sharing and
privacy are, in some sense,
in conflict.
We also need the provenance
and reproducibility.
And the data is unique.
You know, I showed you
a piece of my genome
at the very beginning.
We're going to talk
about that a little more.
But the vast
majority of my genome
is exactly the same as the
vast majority of your genome.
So it doesn't really
make sense to not
have very special-- If we're
going to store exabytes
of this data, then we might
as well have very specialized
systems that are
super good at handling
the details of
this kind of data.
So sharing, how
should sharing work?
Well, today when Google and
Facebook run their companies,
they build data centers
all over the world that
have very large scale.
And those data centers
cover the globe
in a kind of
planet-scale computer.
And when something
needs to be computed,
you move the
question to the data.
And we should be doing that too.
So if I'm here at
Harvard, and I have-- we
have several data
centers at Harvard.
There's one at the Macy's
building, actually, downtown.
Most people were
unlikely to know that.
There's a very large
data center downtown.
And so you want to be able to
move the question to that data
center.
And if you have a
collaborator in the UK,
then you want to be able to
move the question to that data
center.
And you don't want to say, hey,
please ship me some hard drives
with genomes on them.
That's what you
don't want to do.
And of course, federation
can be optional.
Your data is very private.
You don't want your doctor
to share it with anybody.
But you do want your
doctor to have it.
So there's no need
for federation
if that's your preference.
Now, Mark Zuckerberg
and Larry Page,
they have these planet-scale
computing systems.
But they don't have a need to
share the way that biomed does.
They don't share their customer
records with each other.
They don't really share much
of anything with each other.
And they don't have to.
But in biomed we
do need to do it.
Now, I could spend this
entire talk talking
about governance of data.
I think the only thing I'd
like you to appreciate,
because I'm a person who's
comfortable making my data
public, but before I
became a biophysicist,
I was a cryptographer.
And I am very conscious
about privacy and security.
And I want to know
if I promise you
that I'm going to keep your data
private that I really mean it.
And so I would
like those promises
to be based on some
kind of public scrutiny.
So the systems that
keep your data private,
because your preferences are
to keep your data private,
should be based on
real world systems that
are run on public data where
people like me and others
have made their data public.
And so you can be assured
that people, cryptographers,
security experts have actually
tried to sort of crack
into those systems and really
tested how secure they are.
So even though I'm
talking primarily today
about public data and
open source software,
the reason I care
about these things
is so that your data is private
if that's what you want.
And so it's something
that is really
a very important principle.
But even though you yourself
might not be a cryptographer,
you can go to people
that you trust
who are authorities on
analyzing cryptographic systems.
And you could say, hey,
should I trust these people
with my data?
And if all of the systems that
have your data are open source,
then they can be audited.
And you can get
that kind of answer.
If everything is
proprietary, then you sort of
have to trust the company
that they're doing everything
that they say that
they're doing.
OK, so provenance--
this is Charles Darwin.
Obviously, all life
on Earth is connected
through an evolutionary process.
And when we're doing these
very large computations,
we want-- especially--
I mean, it's
hard to appreciate, really,
how big an exabyte is.
But it really is quite big.
So if you are doing
computations at that scale,
you want to know that those
complications are reproducible.
Could you do that computation
twice and get the same answer?
One of the things that
computer scientists are
used to when they
work at this scale
is that unlike your computer at
home, which probably will work,
and if it doesn't work, you
will just turn it on and off
and try again, computations
at the exascale
are guaranteed to have
computers that break.
So you can't just turn
off your million computers
and turn them back on.
You have to be
tolerant of failure.
And so provenance gets
very, very important.
You really want
to be able to know
the history of a computation,
how it was done, and so on.
So hopefully this
is an amusing slide.
So this is Paris
Hilton up there.
She's the blue on
this graph here.
So she was much more--
and the red line here
is searches for cancer.
And the yellow line is
searches for medicine.
So Paris Hilton was
much more important
than cancer and
medicine at least
several times in the history
of the internet searches.
But on the whole, cancer and
medicine are pretty important.
And so what I'm
hoping to get you
to think about is that as an
internet company, Facebook,
Google, really, the biggest
commercial enterprises
responsible for
building this kind
of planet-scale infrastructure
that I'm talking about,
you know, their
use case is people
searching for Paris Hilton.
And so in biomed,
we care a lot more
about explaining why did your
doctor make this decision based
on this report they
generated 10 years ago?
Recreating the exact search for
Paris Hilton from 10 years ago,
far less important.
And so provenance is just
much more important in biomed
than it is in the
internet world.
And I've already
mentioned unique data,
but this is-- it's just a
fact that all life on earth
is ribosome-based.
There are very small
differences in the ribosome
across organisms on Earth.
And so everyone has a genome.
All life on Earth has genomes.
And ultimately,
they have proteins.
And so this whole sort of
mechanism of life on Earth
has a huge amount in common.
We have a lot in
common with each other.
And we have a lot in
common with other species.
And so you don't
have to share-- you
don't have to store every
little bit of that exabyte.
You could potentially
compress the data enormously
if you take
advantage of the fact
that this data is so unique.
So when we weave all
of these together,
at the Personal
Genome Project we
built something
called Arvados, which
is a platform, if
you want to call it
that, that's open
source that includes
all of these components.
It's been running on
systems like this.
It runs in the cloud.
So it runs on
Amazon Web Services.
It runs on Google
Cloud Platform.
And it's the thing that powers
the Personal Genome Project.
And it can power
lots of other things.
But the idea is that because
Arvados is open source,
we can run it everywhere.
We can run it in the cloud.
We can run it in
private data centers.
We can use it to stitch
together this sort
of planet-scale
computer that I've
been talking about across
organizational boundaries.
This diagram is not important.
But the Arvados.org at the
bottom, the URL is important.
There is a very vibrant
open source community
around this project.
The Sanger Institute
in the UK, all sorts
of pharmaceutical
companies, lots of people
are really starting to realize,
why are we all recreating
this infrastructure?
It's completely not competitive.
The pharmas call
this pre-competitive.
But it allows-- it means
that-- I had a high school
student, actually,
for two weeks, who
just finished last week.
And so they were using Arvados.
And they were
contributing to Arvados.
And I didn't really
need to make them
sign any super-complicated
agreements,
because it's all
open and public.
So you can just go
and contribute to it.
If you have a niece
or a nephew that
wants to play with this
stuff, this project
is pretty unique
in terms of making
that possible without normally
the sort of onerous legal
agreements you would
expect working with Harvard
Med or something like that.
So a component of
Arvados is this part
of the software that
handles genomes, that names
parts of your genome.
The system is called Lightning.
The idea is that it's very fast.
It operates in real time
over-- it will actually
be able to answer questions
in less than a second.
Over time we hope it will
do that at planet scale.
So your doctor
could ask a question
on their mobile
device, and genomes
would be interrogated
all over the world.
And not just genomes, but
other kinds of biomedical data.
And you don't want to
just ask, do other people
have exactly this feature
that I'm interested in?
But you also might
ask for things
like, are there other patients
that are similar to my patient?
And in those kinds of
queries, in the past
the way it would
work is-- actually,
the way it works in
clinical genetics
is that all the clinical
geneticists know each other.
There's only maybe
a few thousand.
And they get together
at the same conferences.
And so when they
see a patient that
looks like another
doctor they know
might have a similar
patient, they just
call them up on the
phone or they email them,
and they say, hey, do you
have a patient so-and-so
with these features?
But this isn't going
to work, right?
I mean you can't rely on
phone calls and emails
now that we're generating
millions of genetic features
for every single person.
It just cannot possibly work.
And even in the old
world, the doctors
could talk to each other,
and they would eventually
realize they're talking about
the same genetic feature
because Dr. A would
call it one thing.
Doctor B would call
it something else.
And so in the course
of the conversation
they would come to an
agreement, oh, yeah, we're
really talking about
the same thing,
or, actually, we're not
talking about the same thing.
Again, can't do
that if we really
are working at this
scale with millions
of features per patient.
So in the process of
building Lightning,
it's worth keeping in
mind the doctors are
doing clinical genetics today.
And they've been doing
clinical genetics for decades.
And there are
standards organizations
that have been around, I think,
since the '50s, actually,
in the field called
cytogenetics.
And the way-- what these
pictures are reminiscent of
is actual microscope
staining of your DNA.
So you take your DNA.
You put a stain on it.
You look at it under
the microscope.
You try to stretch it so
it's kind of straight.
And it looks kind of
like these pictures.
So you get bands that are
dark and light depending
on where the stain changed
the color of your DNA.
And so that nomenclature
has been around for decades.
And so part of the
design goal of Lightning
is we need to make sure
that when a doctor asks
for a bit of genome
using the nomenclature
they've been using for 50
years that Lightning knows
about that nomenclature
and that it can talk
to doctors in their language.
So this is a pretty
busy diagram.
But I'll try to explain a little
bit about how Lightning works
and how we name
bits of your genome.
So the important thing is this
unique 24-base tag sequence.
So the idea is that the way we
name genomes, the way that we
decompose them into little
bits that we can all talk about
in a consistent way is
through the standards process.
We pick about 10 million
24-character sequences
that are unique.
And we use them as landmarks.
And once we've picked those
sequences, we call them tags,
then we can decompose your
genome into what we call tiles.
And every tile in
your genome can then
be given a unique name.
And I'll show you some examples.
But-- just show you
in this diagram.
So this is a tag.
It's 24 bases.
And then this is some
sequence in between
that's 200 characters,
just whatever
happens to be in your genome.
Then there's another
unique tag and so forth.
So your whole genome
gets tiled in this way,
with these-- the little
green boxes are the tags that
delimit your genome.
And you have a copy from
mom, let's say on the top,
and then you have a copy
from dad on the bottom.
So you have two sets of bases
that are very, very similar.
So in total you
have about 6 billion
of these characters
in the ACGT alphabet.
And so that's what
your genome is.
And over here, this
little yellow square,
this would be a position where
this person has a sequence that
isn't the common sequence.
It's different from kind of
what most other people have,
especially most other
people of their ethnicity,
because there's-- a lot of
variation is very specific
to different ethnicities.
And then the next encoding
is just another person.
And you can encode millions
of people this way.
And the nice thing
about this encoding
is that it's super compact.
So the raw data for a
genome is 100 gigabytes.
It takes one of these
big, huge hard drives.
I can encode sort of pointers
into this library of sequences,
of tiles, in four megabytes.
So four megabytes you
can attach to an email.
You can send it around.
And for me this is
slightly amusing
because there was a
scientific paper about genomes
as email attachment.
And George Church, pretty much
as soon as the paper came out
was like, yeah,
genomes are four megs.
It's really no problem.
Everything is solved.
We don't have to worry about
these huge 100-gigabyte data
sets anymore.
And I would argue with George.
I would say, no, no, George.
That paper doesn't do this.
And it doesn't do this.
And it doesn't do
this other thing.
We can't use that.
That's-- I'm not even sure it's
physically possible to make
a four-megabyte genome.
But last year we published a
paper with 20-megabyte genomes.
And now we have
four-megabyte genomes.
So George was right,
and I was wrong.
So it is in fact possible.
Just let me show you how
this works with my genome.
So here's-- you can think
of this as a tile, right?
This is just like
a big tile, right?
Lots of As, Cs, Gs, and Ts.
So now I've added tags.
They're blue and underlined.
So there's not
actually one tile here.
There are seven.
And then I'm just going to
reorganize it a little bit.
All the As, Cs, Gs, and
Ts are exactly the same.
I've just moved stuff around so
that the tags are in a column.
And so each one of
these things is a tile.
And the important
tile, the one that
was associated with
cholesterol in my genome,
is this one right here in the
middle in its little red oval.
So this is the same sequence,
the one in the middle.
And this is not-- you know,
there's no fun punchline here.
This number is 32 characters.
It's a unique, consistent
name for this tile up here.
And the nice thing
about this number
is that if you have
that number, it
means you really have this
feature that's associated
with the cholesterol.
It's completely unambiguous.
If two different
labs around the world
sequenced your
genome and my genome
and somebody else's genome, and
they came up with this number,
then you would know that we had
the same feature in our genome.
And that's not the case today.
Today you get a pile of
As, Cs, and Gs and Ts
on your hard drive.
And you might get something
called a variant call file.
And those files can
be very ambiguous.
And so it's actually very, very
easy to end up in a situation
where you're trying
to figure out, well,
does your patient really
have this bit of genome?
No, maybe not.
Maybe.
And so this is
a-- I'm sorry this
is a very technical procedure.
But it is something that
allows us to actually do
this kind of sharing.
And over time, you know, we'll
give these things nicknames
and human-friendly names.
But for now it's good that the
machines have a consistent way
to name bits of your genome.
Because otherwise,
it wouldn't be
possible to automate
these things
that our doctors were doing
just by phone calls and emails.
Diagram is from our paper.
At the top is kind
of a traditional view
of a chromosome.
In the middle there's
kind of a graph structure.
Genomes, you can
start thinking of them
as making graphs where the
tiles in a person's genome
represent all of the one
path through the graph.
And then all of the different
people in the population
have different paths
through the graph.
And then this
particular thing here
is just like the tile I
showed you from my genome.
This is from a PGP
participant's genome.
This is very strongly
associated with breast cancer.
We haven't actually
established that she is aware
that she has this.
She had breast cancer at 66.
So from her
perspective, she already
knows she has breast cancer.
But we did notify
participants about this.
And sometimes participants
get back to us.
Sometimes they don't.
So that's part of the nature of
this kind of public research.
But this is an actually
clinically very important
variant in a genome.
And again, you see
this string, 3552B9.
This is a
computer-generated string
that is unique and
completely unambiguous
in terms of identifying the
feature in this person's
genome.
The nice thing
about this encoding,
so this is called principal
component analysis.
This is a very simple thing
that people do when they
talk about machine learning.
So if I give you lots
of genomes and you
apply this sort of statistical
technique on those genomes,
then what you'll end
up with is people
will separate by ethnicities.
So all the people
who are Caucasian
will end up in one
pile down here.
And people who are
Asian are over here.
African are over here.
And it's kind of
what you expect,
that we have a huge number
of features in our genome
that are very similar to
people of similar ethnicity.
And so you get this
kind of separation.
And this tells you that
our sequencing is working
and that it's not full
of sequencing errors.
But this is a very
rudimentary form
of machine learning that the
encoding-- I mentioned it's not
only compact, but it's extremely
convenient for applying machine
learning techniques to genomes.
And I don't know if anyone
saw the news around this.
I mean, probably people know
that IBM Watson defeated
the Jeopardy champion.
And people know that IBM
also beat the world's chess
champion.
So recently, an actually
much harder victory
was achieved by Google.
So Alpha Go defeated the world's
best Go player, which I think
is probably the hardest board
game that we have in the world.
So machines are
just getting really
good at doing things that human
experts have been good at.
And so I think we can expect
that machine learning is going
to have all sorts of
breakthroughs in biomedicine
over the course of
the next few years.
And these kinds of encodings
and consistent naming schemes
are going to be essential
to make that happen.
So again, Lightning
is federated.
So the idea is that you
can send these queries
all over the world.
Your doctor is working on
their little smartphone.
And queries go out to data
centers all over the world.
And an answer can
come back immediately.
And initially, this is
not going to be deployed
in every physician's office.
This could be a decade
before this happens
in sort of routine care.
But for pharmaceutical
research, for drug discovery,
and also just for
general discovery
by the general public,
I think that people
will want to play with this data
as it becomes more available,
people who have
played with their--
looked at ancestry or
other-- predicting eye
color, blood type.
There's just lots of things
that just pop out of this data.
And so I expect that
people will want
to play with their own data.
Hopefully-- I know this
is a very dry subject.
This is the infrastructure
behind genomics.
And so all of it, though,
although it may be very dry,
it is accessible.
And so my hope is that
even if it isn't something
that you think you
will do personally,
that you do reach
out to your nephews
and nieces and young friends
and invite them to participate
in this very open community,
because you don't need a PhD.
You don't need special,
secret, top security clearance,
because the code is public,
and the data is public.
And this is one of our meetings
at the Personal Genome Project.
I think Jeantine
is nicely featured.
And I'm there as well.
So thank you guys all very much.
I hope I can answer
some questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]